[Music]
welcome to our session opening the doors
to machine learning how triple-a
leverages BQ ml and Google sheets to
predict call volume my name is Sarah
Robinson I'm a developer advocate on the
Google cloud team focus on machine
learning you can find me on twitter at s
rod tweets and later on in the
presentation we'll be hearing from dr.
Chuck Brooks the director of data
strategy at triple A's Auto Club group
and we'll also hear from Matt powers a
senior consultant at maven wave maven
wave help triple a implement their
solution I'm just a reminder that we are
using Dory Q&A for this session so if
you have questions that come up as we're
talking just open up your next app add a
question in the Dory and we will do our
best to answer it at the end so what
we're gonna cover I'm gonna give a
product overview of the qml and app
scripts which we're both used in triple
A's use case Chuck is gonna talk about
what triple A's Auto Auto Club group
does and how they're using bigquery
machine learning and then Matt is gonna
do an end to end live demo of triple A's
use case before we dive into bigquery
machine learning let's talk a little bit
about what bigquery is so bigquery is
our cloud data analytics warehouse it
lets you store and query lots and lots
of data super fast what do we mean by
lots of data petabyte scale storage and
queries and you can do it all in
familiar sequel the great thing about
bigquery is that it's fully managed and
serviced so you don't have to worry
about spinning up any of the
infrastructure to run complex queries
bigquery will handle all of that for you
so bigquery is a great starting point
for machine learning cuz you often need
a lot of data to get started with
machine learning but if you haven't ever
built a machine learning model before
that process can be daunting there's a
lot to learn it's also expensive for
companies to hire enough data scientists
to build these machine learning models
and it's complex and time consuming to
take your data out of a database like
bigquery and feed it into your machine
learning pipeline so let's talk about
the process of how we would build a
custom machine learning model without B
qml we would first identify a problem
that we want to solve with machine
learning and gather our data then we'd
pre process our data so we want to get
it into the right format for
machine learning models so this means if
we had categorical data we would need to
one-hot encode that into arrays then we
would split our data so an important
concept in machine learning is train
test split so you take about 80 percent
of your data use that to train your
model and you set aside about 20 percent
for testing to see how your model
performs on data that it's never seen
before then in step 4 are you actually
writing the code to build your model
choosing your model architecture and
training and evaluating your model you
might repeat steps 4 & 5 a couple of
times until you get accuracy that you're
happy with then finally you'll need to
spin up infrastructure to deploy your
model so that you can handle prediction
requests from your users it's a great
thing about B qml is that it simplifies
this a lot so with B qml all you need to
do is identify a problem that you want
to solve with machine learning gather
your data write a query to train and
evaluate your model and then it's
automatically available to get
predictions so just to summarize some
really great features of B QML lets you
execute ml models without moving your
data from bigquery so you don't have to
take your data out of the data warehouse
and feed it into your ml pipeline you
can do it all right from bigquery you
can iterate on your models and sequel so
it's really fast to train new models try
out different sets of features and
labels and bqm l also automates common
tasks like hyper parameter tuning and
train test split which I talked about
before so this is all the sequel code
you need to build and train your model
in this example we're building a model
to predict how many bikes are in
circulation in New York given some data
on the weather for that day so we tell
it the type of model we want to use the
labels that we're using for the model
and then we tell it what table to grab
the data from and once this query
finishes we've got a train model ready
to go
similarly to generate predictions you
just call ml predict and when you run
this bqm L will add a column called
predicted underscore and then whatever
your label name column name was so
there's some really awesome new and
upcoming features in BQ ml that I want
to highlight model evaluation charts are
now available in the UI so once your
model trains you get a little bit more
insight into how that training process
one and what evaluation looks like
um k-means clustering models are in beta
and then we have a bunch of different
alpha features here matrix factorization
the ability to import tensor flow models
that you've already trained externally
and query them in beak UML feature
pre-processing functions and tensor flow
DNN classifier and DNN regressor models
so if you want to try any of these out
talk to your sales reps or reach out to
me and I can connect you to the right
people just send me a DM on Twitter a
tester of tweets so I never like to get
too far into a presentation without
showing some demos so we're gonna see
some demos of two different types of
beak UML models the first will be a
regression model regression model just
means that our model is predicting a
numerical value so we're gonna see given
the weather how many new york city city
bikes are in circulation and then for
our classification model i've got some
data on different types of candy bars
everyone loves candy and we're gonna see
given some data on a candy bar is it
chocolate or not so let's go to the demo
so this is the bigquery UI and make it a
little bit bigger there we go I've got
some saved queries here so the first
query I'm gonna run is a prediction
query and this is on my bike model and
so what this is gonna do is it's gonna
query my bike model and I've got a test
table here with I believe just four
examples of data that wasn't included in
our training set and we'll see if our
model can get close to predicting the
actual number of trips so this is what
the query looks like very similar to
what you saw on the slide and I'm gonna
run that and it's done and we can now
compare predicted num trips with actual
number of trips and we can see that it's
pretty close here so you get 20,000
20,000 12,000 12,000 all those
predictions are looking pretty good
so that was a prediction for a
regression model now I'm gonna show a
prediction for our chocolate
classification model so let's take a
look at the data here's our test data
and what this model is going to predict
is whether or not it's chocolate
so 0 for not chocolate 1 for chocolate
and so when we run this query we'll see
that the output is a little bit
different than what we get in the
regression model so this is telling us
the predicted class for each input but
we also get data on the probability that
the particular input belongs to this
class so what this is telling us is that
there is a 97% chance that this is a
chocolate candy bar and then three
percent chance that it's not similarly
for this one we get 93% and then these
two it both it predicted both of these
correctly as chocolate so we get no 99%
confidence for this one and 90 nearly
98% confidence for that one so that is
how you generate predictions on models
and be QML but I also want to show you
how easy it is to train a new model in
beak UML so I want to show you the query
that we use to train that chocolate
classification model and I'm actually
going to change this a little bit so
this was a classification problem we're
gonna change this to a regression
problem so another item from our dataset
is the popularity of each candy bar as a
percentage in the data set it's called
win percent so we're gonna change this
and all we need to do to change it to a
regression model is change this model
type to linear regression we now need to
collect our new label column which is
win percent and then we will change the
labels to that so I'm going to kick this
off it should take about a minute to run
but again the great thing about what B
qml is doing here is it's making this
whole process a lot simpler so what used
to take you know weeks or maybe even
months of doing all these steps of you
know collecting your data getting it
into the right format converting
categorical data to arrays under the
hood B qml is taking care of all that
for you so when our model finishes we
should be able to run a query very
similar to the bike regression query
that we saw here and you saw how easy it
is to develop models it are iteratively
so if I wanted to add new features maybe
switch my label it's just a matter of
changing a couple
a sequel I don't need to rebuild my
model code from scratch so be qml really
simplifying a lot of these steps for us
and again the query should finish in
about a minute there we go so our models
created we will go to our model and we
can see that this is what our model
schema looks like so we'll get this
predicted win percent value and if we go
back to our save queries we will just
modify this query slightly to query from
our new model which we called chocolate
underscore percent and we'll add the win
percentage field to it too so we'll run
this query and see how our model does it
predicting candy popularity so here we
get the predicted percentage of 42 if we
scroll over here the actual was 39 we
can compare the rest of them 39:35 and
it looks pretty close across the board
for our predicted and our actual so that
there you can see how simple it is to
generate predictions and also train new
models in BQ ml so if we could go back
to the slides so there's an endless
number of possibilities of different
model types that you could build and
bigquery machine learning I'm not going
to go into all of these on this slide
but you get the idea of how you could
apply it across many different
industries and the other products that
Triple A used in their implementation is
Apps Script
and what is Apps Script Apps Script is a
server list JavaScript runtime 4G suite
automation so it lets you really easily
connect different Google products it's
entirely serverless so the code editor
lives in your browser but the scripts
run on Google servers it's written in a
language based on JavaScript so if you
know JavaScript you're good to go
getting started with Apps Script and it
lets you automate tax tasks across
different Google products I really like
this code snippet example so what this
is doing is in the first row we're
getting a row from a spreadsheet which
is an address then we're creating a
static map of that address and then
emailing that map to somebody so in just
five lines of code we can
Google sheets Google Maps and Gmail and
you can also connect additional api's
using Apps Script through what's called
advanced Google services so this is what
we'll use to connect bigquery in the
demo format that you'll see later on so
using the advanced services you don't
have to worry at all about
authentication so it's just as if you
were using the regular bigquery client
library in your Apps Script code G suite
add-ons allow developers to build many
applications that live alongside top G
suite Apps there installable domain wide
and we use add-ons in the demo that
you'll see shortly to embed a tool
within Google sheets as a sidebar so
just to summarize the different use
cases that we've seen with BQ ml so far
we've seen customers use BQ ml to
simplify existing workflows so take
existing machine learning pipelines
custom pipelines and then move those
over to be qml we've also seen BQ ml as
a great entry point to machine learning
so for data analysts that might not have
experience with ml and their data is
already in bakery they can just write
some sequel queries to get started
training custom machine learning models
and then we've also seen it used to
complement existing machine learning
workflows so let's say you have a custom
machine learning pipeline but you've got
a new idea and you want to test it out
to see if it'll work to see if there's a
relationship between a specific set of
features and labels so we've seen a
bunch of customers using BQ ml so far
and I'm really excited to introduce dr.
Chuck Brooks the director of data
strategy at triple A's Auto Club group
to tell us more about their use case
take it away Chuck thank you sir
mmm I am dr. Chuck Brooks and I am from
from the Auto Club group how many folks
know of Triple A oh yeah how many Triple
A members do we have even better that's
what I'm talking about okay so for you
that know about us you probably know
about our roadside services certainly if
you're a member you know about our
roadside services it's pretty common
service that we offer but perhaps you
didn't know that we're that we really
have 12 lines of business and
many of them have nothing to do with
roadside so we offer a full travel
agency perhaps you didn't know that we
have a full bank that we offer life
insurance and and full line of insurance
products including home and auto and we
in many of the states that we service we
we do car repairs so automotive repair
services as well what do these all have
in common well for us it's all about the
customer right it's all about offering
services to our customer that enriched
their experience and their lives and the
things that they have to do every day
it's all about handling those tough
situations right I mean when your car is
broken down on the side of the road or
you get up in the morning and you go out
to start the car and it doesn't start
you need some help and we want to be
there for you so when our customers call
it's important that we be there to
answer the phone of course we're doing
digital transformation like many folks
and and you can do a lot more on your
phone or with a text or on our mobile
app but when you reach out we need to be
there for you
and so when I joined Triple A just some
short 10 months ago we needed to bring
the data together from all of those
lines of business like many companies
our data was siloed inside of each one
of the lines of business and in fact the
different lines of business and the data
there couldn't talk to each other have
you experienced that before in your
organization's would you be surprised if
I told you that the banking customers
the banking organization didn't know who
our 10 million members were I was and
I've seen this right I've been doing
this for almost 40 years
and and I've seen silos of data but we
had taken it to a whole new level so we
began to build a data Lake and we began
to use GCP products to do that primarily
bigquery but the rest of the data stores
as well we began to move our data in and
we began to integrate it and we began to
put it in formats where it was usable
where analysts could look at it and they
could understand what was happening
across our organization but as we did
that one of the things that that I
noticed was that we hadn't made it easy
for analysts who weren't sequel
developers to necessarily get to that
data and so I looked across the GCP
platform and I said well what can we use
what tools can we bring into play that
allow analysts who not aren't
necessarily sequel developers to be more
effective in our environment and I
thought bigquery Google sheets because
everybody knows spreadsheets and let's
love spreadsheets and be qml and I said
how can we bring these together to begin
to predict how many call center agents
we need to have available at any given
time so that when our customers call we
can be there and so I reached out to one
of our trusted partners I hope you guys
know the folks from maven wave we work
with them regularly they do some great
work with us they don't try to do the
work for us they like to work with us
and if you're working with partners you
know how important that is so let me
introduce Matt and Matt can show you a
little bit about the application that
we've created it's been sanitized a
little bit but you'll get the idea oh
thank you dr. truck Brooks is a great
great intro so yeah maven wave is a
Google premier partner on the right hand
side here we've got the different ways
that
maven waves broken down it's different
practices and it's actually pretty
closely aligned with the different
different global products that are out
there so data analytics something I'll
be focusing on today things like
bigquery ml and and although they're
great machine learning tools and
capabilities that that Google has and
everything from enterprise collaboration
so helping companies you know integrate
G suite into their environments so again
thank you dr. Chuck Brooks so now
focusing on the problem so it struck
mentioned you know answering the call
being able to answer the call at the
different call centers it's crucial to
Triple A being there when someone calls
when you know they're in an accident or
their vehicle you know the flat tire or
whatever it may be they need to be there
to answer the call so that was really
crucial for this this use case so we've
got some of the KPIs for Triple A call
centers things like the customer
experience the agent utilization the
cost and all of these things can be tied
back to is an agent in the call center
do they have the right staff for this
call center so with that in mind the the
problem that we're trying to solve is
how can we always make sure that someone
is there in the call center to answer
answer the call so with that being the
problem what was the solution and Chuck
and Sarah have both hit on this but we
wanted to make it very easily to run a
lot of different scenarios to be able to
predict what that call demand was going
to be so we built a model using B qml as
Sarah walk through we then wanted to
expose the model to users throughout the
organization and very you know easy to
use way and we did that through Google
sheets and the Google sheets add-on and
again by doing this it's allowed users
with little-to-no ml experience it's
really utilize the power of machine
learning to run these these different
what-if scenarios so the end result
before kind of jumping in a demo here so
we used we created a be qml model we
integrated that into Google sheets and
then that integration was possible
through Apps Script other you know les
note here's there's two weeks of
development time so these tools because
we're using both GCP and g suite the
integration between these two is fairly
simple and you know pretty pretty quick
development time to get to a good
Minimum Viable Product
so with that I'd like to turn over a
demo great so I live here we've got a
Google sheet you know most people are
gonna be familiar most users a Triple A
are gonna be familiar with this type of
experience you don't need any sequel
skills to kind of navigate your your way
around here so we've got a few different
inputs that went into our model so we've
got things like state county month
what's the member segments because they
don't Triple A doesn't want to just
predict a call volume of a county they
want to predict the call volume of a
specific member segment we've also got
things like population and the per
capita income during that year and then
finally the member count in that in that
community and then that member segment
so what we've done here is we've created
two what-if scenarios so we said you
know what if per capita income goes up
for the the Florida Bay County and then
the second one we looked at you know
what if the member cow increases by 10%
every single year you know how is that
going to change the call volume for that
call center and then you know from that
you know what sort of higher and what
sort of hiring decisions does triple I
need to make in order to staff that
staff that properly so we've got our two
what-if scenarios and what I've done up
here is just as Sarah's mentioned this
is a Google sheets add-on so again this
was created all through Google Apps
Script what I'll do is I'll highlight
all the things that go into the model so
the X range and then I'll tell B qml
where I want the the output to display
so I hit run model there and what it did
behind the scenes is we created a model
in B qml and then we're now surfacing
the results so you know we gave it the
the input data and now we're surfacing
the results in column I here so we can
see that for the first scenario as
per-capita income goes up it looks like
they're the predicted call volume will
go up you know slightly for the next one
if the member count increases by 10%
every year there will be some
substantial growth in the and the
predicted call volume for for Triple A
so that it at a high level is the demo
and you know it's just highlighting all
the different what-if scenarios that an
analyst can now play they could you know
change the state change
County change a member segment you know
what happens if the population decreases
so a bunch of what-if scenarios that are
you know can be utilized by anyone
anyone in triple-a so now jumping back
to the slides so kind of a few more you
know diving a little bit deeper into you
know what problems does it solve and how
does this help Triple A so machine
learning is becoming easier and easier
to use now that you've opened up to like
spreadsheets the users would that have
the ability to interact with spreadsheet
is obviously greater than the users that
have sequel skills or even you know
specific machine learning Python skills
so greater adoption is definitely
possible using something like this
through Google sheet now kind of talking
about a model delivery cycle so here's
you know the typical ml process you
start with the business objective and
then all the things highlighted in blue
are in our areas where B qml can really
help you with the with the full model
life cycle process the first two they're
the exploring and data selection and
then the pre-processing most of the time
in machine learning work that's seventy
percent of the challenge and seventy
percent of where the time span is
getting the the right amount of data get
enough of it making sure you know you do
that exploratory data analysis you find
what features are important and then the
pre-processing so be qml can't solve all
these problems but it does do a few key
things to help you with this process so
the explore and data selection so in the
in the example I just showed per capita
income and population I was actually
able to get that through big queries
public datasets
they've curated a great public datasets
everything from census data to weather
data all sorts of great information and
the ability to now join that join that
open source data set into your model is
just a sequel join you don't need to go
out and buy any sort of data set it's
just a sequel join so that was first
thing as far as the exploration it was
all done through a sequel interface
which is fairly easy and then they've
also got a bunch of other great tools
things like data prep and data studio to
do that data visualization and that
exploratory data analysis which is so
important for a machine
problems then the pre-processing so some
great things that that handles behind
the scenes for you so one hot encoding
so for those of you who are familiar
with machine learning if you have any
categorical features like the state or
the county - then you need to convert
that into some array as Sarah is talking
about so essentially a rows of zeros and
ones that's all done for you
automatically behind the scenes with
bigquery so can handle categorical
features and then the handles missing
data so if you have any missing data it
will you there's ways that you can you
can set how you want it to handle it but
out of the box
it'll put the the median value in there
for you so just you know it won't solve
you know all the pre-processing and data
selection steps but there's a lot of
great things that make that process
easier in the Google ecosystem and with
BQ ml and then the the rest of the cycle
a BQ ml can handle a lot of this so
model selection Sara hit on they're
coming out with more and more models
every day and then the tray and evaluate
tune predict and serve that is all done
through BQ ml so now we've created this
model we've exposed in Google sheets how
do you actually you know deploy this in
an organization and that's kind of what
this slide is getting at here so we've
got you know our data scientists and
data analysts building these models in B
qml they've built model a B and C you
know for predicting call volume
predicting where accidents are gonna
happen all these different things that
you can predict now I want to expose
this to the organization so we have the
Google sheet on the right and really the
only thing you need to do to expose that
expose that model to your organization
is you need to give a a user who wants
to use a model access to the underlying
data set and the model inside a bigquery
so it's as simple as provisioning a user
access to that model and that data set
and then you know users throughout the
organization can can utilize this the
last step in in the kind of areas that
you know we know as Triple A to the
maven Y partnership we we need to grow
this is giving you that users better
insights into how the models performing
so we're just giving them the output but
what's the accuracy give them give users
the confidence interval that you know
the predicted call vine is gonna between
gonna be between you know x and y so
just kind of giving them a black box
here's the answer giving them more
insight into you know what how accurate
is this so it's not just use blindly so
that's that's an area that you know
we're working on and figuring out the
best way to expose that to to users who
again aren't as familiar with a big
query machine learning so with that I'm
gonna turn over to Chuck to talk about
some of the value they've seen so far
triple F thanks man
so is that was that cool is that cool
stuff I mean these guys do a great job
of presenting that that's great stuff
right let me let me ask you do you think
folks in your organization analysts in
your organization can use these tools
probably yeah okay good
look we got we've got three thousand
agents across five call centers handling
over 15 million calls a year and I got
to tell you that this is working for us
early MVP results show that we can begin
to reduce call times because we're
accurately able to put the right staff
in place on a regular basis now that's
huge for us for all of the reasons that
I mentioned when our customers call we
need to be there
[Music]